we can talk to two couples on both sides
of the process so i'm joined now by
sabrina edge and her daughter kitty who
are in drift field in yorkshire and by
lilia and vitali malone who have fled
ukraine are now in moldava and are
hoping to join the edge family well
welcome to all of you sabrina let's um
let's kick off with your side of it then
shall we why did you feel compelled to
try and help
um well it's not the first time we've
been on a scheme like this and we were
with positive housing in action in 2016.
so it's always as a family being an idea
for us we've got a spare room um
and we just were watching the news with
the break out of the war and we just
felt compelled that we had to you know
offer
two rooms that we have
and this was
nearly three weeks ago um so you know it
was before the government had even
announced any scheme any incentive
nothing like that it was just purely on
a we need to help we've got the
availability let's do something
wow so you got there before the
government uh fascinating well let's go
to lilia
in moldova and you've obviously managed
to get out of ukraine so tell us your
story then where were you and why did
you decide to flee
yeah
uh
one morning we woke up with such bad
news yes uh and i can say that
why it was
unexpectable because it was a very early
morning yes we were preparing to take
our kids to school and we are preparing
to get
to our place workplace i mean and you
know my
aunt called me in the morning and said
you know
wake up quickly because it's gonna be
dangerous today to stay at home because
i could see some worse sorry some
rockets in the sky always my house and
she lives 120 kilometers away from us
and it was like an evidence i mean that
um
it's a very close person called me and
she said me if i saw something maybe
online i wouldn't believe
and i was starting
crying because i didn't know what
exactly to do and then we heard this
alarm serenas and to tell the truth the
basements were not ready to
uh for
accepting people i mean they were
wet and dirty so we couldn't stay there
for long there wasn't any water and so
on and we were really scared i didn't
know what to do my children were crying
i was crying too my husband tried to
support but
we decided to we live just not far away
from moldova so that we decided to
to leave this place to go to abroad
because it would we decided it would be
better for our family to stay there
so so why the uk perhaps you could ask
your husband vitaly how he feels about
going to the united kingdom
he is very glad that we have such
opportunity to change something yes in
our life because we can't see any future
here
especially for our two daughters they
are still young yes they're they're not
ready for such like like with war i mean
that we want to protect them first of
all
and um
um
of course he's a little bit worried
because he can't speak english very well
but uh as i i speak english very well so
it was my decision to go to the
english-speaking country first and we
were thinking which one to choose and we
found this family and to tell the truth
they
their support made us to go to uk
well that that's lovely isn't it and
sabrina then so how did that sort of
connection part of it happen because
that's been confusing a lot of people
how you get matched up with another
family
well we were lucky and my daughter my
eldest daughter um sent a facebook group
um that she'd seen and i think two weeks
ago there was a couple of hundred people
on it and i think now is like 50 000
people on it and there was a um
it guys that developed a website in 24
hours um from madrid and i found them
put in my details lilia did that
two weeks ago today um and she sent me a
message on the 4th of march an email
saying you know could we have a chat we
spoke and you know that's what we've
been doing ever since a lot of face
times a lot tour around the house
and all of us have just got this real
nice friendship that's you know sort of
naturally
bloomed and we've all got similar
interests the girls have got a whatsapp
group with their eldest daughter
victoria
so we're just desperate we did the
application today it took three hours
um and we're still no further forward on
a date so we can't plan they can't plan
it's just
you know
stressful
so lilia what are you holding up and
tell us about your children and how they
feel how old are they and how do they
feel about coming um what what is quite
a distance from ukraine to be fair
yeah um uh these are my our four
passports yeah uh because we i worked
with them i mean that we changed the
information sabrina sent me her copies
of the password i sent her our
information so
uh we had a hectic day but luckily we uh
completed the application online and um
yeah we have two more daughters um
victory is 14 and ilona is only six
unfortunately they went to sleep because
they were tired today yes they're also
worried
about moving to other countries because
sometimes they say oh we want to come
back home but unfortunately i don't know
how to say that we can't back come back
all the things are there and they
sometimes want to take
some toys and they say unfortunately we
can't take all of them so i mean that
yeah we are very lucky i can say so and
i hope a lot of families will be
as as lucky as we are yes they will be
able to apply unfortunately
not all ukrainians speak english yes and
the website is not in in russian or in
ukrainian and this is a problem yes
because only i could apply myself but
usually people for them it's really
difficult to apply because everything is
in english
i did see one thing actually that the
home secretary put out in ukrainian so
hopefully that will be changing um but
kitty i wonder if i could um speak to
you i don't know how you how old you are
how close you are in age to victoria as
well and how you feel about having you
know effectively more children in the
house
um
well
i'm 11
and
i don't feel like
uncomfortable with them coming like
i've spoke to them on like a what's up
group and like we've got to know each
other
so like
i don't know what to say well we've done
lots of face time yeah you're
comfortable you come yeah yeah
well i'm sure it's going to be amazing
um it's going to be interesting
certainly for you and all the other
families who want to join one final
thought from
from you uh lilia and vitali obviously
you know you're desperate to to move as
soon as you can um but will you always
look back at ukraine and watch the
pictures of what's happening in your
country with sadness and of course the
hope to return there
yeah of course we are going to fall yes
and of course we have such feelings that
we we don't need to leave our country
yes and there is like a pain in my heart
that they have to do it unfortunately
yes because of this all this bad circle
circumstances yes and um sometimes i
think oh should i really do it or maybe
i should do something but i i understand
that we have to do it because
it's really becomes really dangerous for
example there was a rocket along the
river which we are live near yeah i can
see the rivers through the window there
was a rocket flying to vinitza yes and
it was destroyed in the air it was it it
turned just
next to our town to vinitza to the and
you know it's becoming more and more
dangerous to stay here
best to keep your children safe isn't it
um we really appreciate you all joining
us we wish you the very best of luck uh
lilia and vitali malone and i'm sure
they'll be english lessons for for all
the people who can't speak english and
also sabrina and kitty edge
well done to both of you and fingers
crossed you get to move soon thank you
very much indeed